in 2006 Netflix famously offered a prize
to solve a simple problem which had been
around for years all online commerce
giants are fighting to get better at
solving this same problem given
observations of a user's past behavior
predict which other things that same
user will like for example based on
Alice's viewing history will she like
the matrix or grapes of wrath' we can
represent user preferences graphically
as connections between people on one
side and things on the other such as
movies here the strength of connection
is visually represented by the thickness
of the lines so the problem is to fill
out all of these missing connections we
don't yet know shown in red but because
of the messy unpredictable nature of
people's tastes we can never perfectly
predict what they will like because for
one it involves a guess about the future
based on something you've never seen and
two the answer is always in flux because
people's tastes change over time what we
can do is try to estimate those values
as best we can using whatever data we
have access to so regardless of the
context we can describe the problem in
the following mathematical form
we use a matrix which is a collection of
numbers organized into rows and columns
where the rows are users and the columns
are items in this case movies and each
cell in this matrix contains a number
that describes how much each individual
likes each movie for example we could
use a scale from 0 to 4 where a 0 would
represent I hate it
2 is neutral and 4 as I love it at any
given moment there will be some set of
preference data for users and movies but
it will be incomplete because users have
only seen and rated a few movies each
and so the problem boils down to trying
to predict these missing values how
should we make these predictions there
are two general approaches to this
problem the first is called content
filtering which is to use information we
know about people in things as
connective tissue for recommendations
it's like asking Alice questions about
what kinds of movie she likes to figure
out if she will like the matrix it
begins by labeling each person and
movies with some known attributes or
what we call features for example action
and comedy that means if Alice likes
comedy and hates action we can represent
her as 3 0 each movie is also mapped to
each feature in the same way for example
that matrix has no comedy and lots of
action so we could represent it as 0 4
and to determine whether someone will
like a movie we need to multiply these
factors together so we could represent
the strength of connection between Alice
and the matrix as 3 times 0 plus 0 times
4 equals 0 so our estimation is that she
will hate the movie so to make our
predictions we first need to gather this
feature data for every user and movie to
simplify let's return to a matrix
representation we can store this
information in two matrices one defines
the mapping between people and features
the other defines the mapping between
movies and futures and by multiplying
these two matrices together using matrix
multiplication we get an estimated
strength of connection between every
person and movie and if we'd like we can
normalize our data to make sure the
scale stays between 0 and 4 by dividing
all values by 8 and rounding to the
nearest point 5 that's one way to solve
this problem known as content filtering
the problem is it's overly simplistic
and not very accurate that's because
there are obviously more relevant
features of a movie than just comedy or
action the obvious way to improve this
is just to include more features if you
recall when Netflix started it did just
this it would ask new users to fill out
a laundry list of questions about their
preferences before presenting them with
suggested movies and this leads to the
problem of having to collect all of this
preference data on users not only is it
a burden for users it's also prone to
failure as we aren't always great at
describing our own preferences sometimes
we simply can't explain why we like
things we just do which brings us to the
other approach called collaborative
filtering the motivation for
collaborative filtering comes from the
idea that you will probably like things
people with similar viewing habits also
like this idea was popularized in this
2009 paper by Cohen Bell and wolinski so
to begin we can throw away the idea of
dreaming up features used to connect
peoples and movies instead we flip
things around and use the user
preference data we do have to generate
the features for example we might have
this incomplete set of preference data
and we will instead learn or discover
the relevant features based on patterns
in this data and this is done by simply
reversing the problem we first perform
an approximate factorization into two
matrices and we can do this using a
machine learning approach the job of the
machine learning algorithm is to guess
values for those matrices which will
match the existing data and the
preference matrix as closely as possible
the simplest approach is to simply guess
numbers over and over until you arrive
at a set of numbers which predict the
data with the lowest air overall once
this estimation is finished we can
multiply the matrices as before to fill
in all of the missing values and it's
important to note that we won't know
exactly what to label these discovered
features so we call them latent features
because they arise out of the underlying
patterns and the data you can think of
them as an average or weighted sum of
the patterns in the data they are not
based on a human defined feature such as
comedy and that's the key insight behind
this method with content filtering the
features come from the human mind
whereas with collaborative filtering the
features are extracted directly from the
patterns in the data and this will
predict the data in the same way but
more accurately it's also important to
notice that this kind of prediction is
actually a form of compression because
we can represent a huge matrix of
preference data by two smaller matrices
of feature data and once our feature
data is determined or learned we can
throw away the original data we started
with because we can simply multiply the
features together to recreate that data
and the reason this is possible is
because the preference data we started
with is not random but follow patterns
which exist across people if instead the
preference data was filled with random
numbers we would not be able to compress
it accurately because there would be no
patterns to extract this collaborative
filtering approach has also been applied
to a wide range of context such as
evaluating policy outcomes before they
are implemented in the real world known
as synthetic control for example if we
wanted to understand the effect of gun
control or minimum wage increases in
some city we could look at the effect in
similar cities first which have
implemented those policies to
approximate the outcome using the same
mechanism so it is the patterns we share
that allow this method to work
recommendation systems based on the
ideas are in widespread use today
whether it's movies music news articles
or anything else you search for online
the things that are recommended to you
are based on patterns the machine has
observed in other people who are similar
to yourself